which brings me to another interesting
point um
you also had a conversation about uh
using anger
during your debates right with other
people and you made the self-criticism
that you felt that
in the beginning during the debates you
might have been too mild
too soft to the opponents and that you
switched up your style right
so what was the observation that you
made in doing that because i think a lot
of starting people
starting muslims doing debates etc can
fall into the same
uh the same trap yes what was the
observation there i think
this is actually a matter of creed um
and i know it sounds a little bit uh
maybe unusual but there are some people
you need to be angry about and hate for
the sake of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says
you know you will not find the people
that
believe in allah and his messenger
uh sorry on the last day who you are
dunamis
they're showing love to those who show
opposition to allah as messenger
even if they were their fathers and
their their brothers and uh
the extended family the ashira why would
you not find that because
it's not possible and this is a very
important distinction yeah
a lot of people ask the question why are
we like that with david wood trying to
humiliate him
you know i had to imagine him like he
said
i had an objective to humiliate david
and the reason why is because he was
manhattan
he was a person who he was not a he he
was
not a person who's just a disbeliever a
disbeliever even if they vocalize their
disbelief
you don't have any reason to be horrible
to them or to speak badly to them but if
they are
into the field of gratuitous insult
mockery and trying to attack
you through your sacred items and
religion
then i believe those individuals need to
be opposed you know
um with harshness i i don't think it
is even islamically legitimate to be
kind with those people i think it's
haram to be kind to those individuals
that's my best my belief system
if someone has is on the record uh
and they have been they've been uh
mocking of the rasulallah they have been
attacking you know islam and the muslims
and you're nice to them
that is a that's haram to be like that
in my opinion because the quran says
so if there's three criteria in here if
the people are not trying to kill you
like allah says you know
they don't try and kill you for your
religion
yeah and they don't try and kick you out
of your homes and number three they
don't try and
uh oppose allah and his messenger then
we can be
if you don't do these three things to me
then we can have a nice conversation
and i have no reason to be disrespectful
to you then you have
then you the default position is that
i'm going to be respectful to you
but if you have said something about
prophet muhammed on the record
or if you have done something rude or
have attacked the muslims on the record
then expect from me
expect a harshness do not expect
kindness
and if kindness is you know
the quran says do not do jedel
do not argue with al-qaeda except with
that which is better
except for the ones who have done valm
of them
so in other words i think it was a it's
not a mistake some died to make this
mistake
they make the mistake thinking that i
have to be kind in all cases and they do
still
with the with the hadith
the goodness wasn't in anything except
that it made it beautiful and it wasn't
taken away from anything
except that i made it beautiful yeah
that's true as a
that if we accept that and we accept
also
yeah we accept also that our responses
should be
proportionate because in the beginning
of the hadith those jews said to the
prophet muhammad alaykum may death be
upon you
and she went further this this is that
he said look don't say this just say
and you're as well you know be
proportionate don't be
too much right even if it was someone
who's
you know whatever like you know um
but at the same time don't show love to
an enemy
that's a big mistake people make if
someone has made an enemy out of you and
you show them love that's ignorance and
that's weakness it's not uh
courteous it's not uh nice it's not it's
ability here ascend
islam wouldn't be it's not even it's
actually not halal
it's not halal it's not good it's haram
and allah has
harsh words to say about people that do
that and unfortunately we need to make
the disclaimer we're not talking about
physical attacking them or
no of course not just right right just
by discussion we need to
add the disclaimer